the last 24 hours I've seen a great many
explosions both in Moscow but also in
Kiev as well and clearly this air
campaign this campaign of drones Kiev
against Moscow Moscow against Kiev
appears appears to be in a rather
dramatic phase
this increased tempo of air action if
that's what it is certainly matters
because it indicates that the major
offensive that Ukraine is about to begin
is very imminent the Russians have
stepped up their air campaign
tremendously against Ukraine in recent
days since the first of May they've
launched 17 different attacks and three
of those attacks have come in the last
24 hours so they clearly think that
something is about to happen and Kiev
has made it very clear that the
offensive is now imminent the orders
have been given said zielinski and we'll
see them play out in the coming days I
suspect it would be very concerning I
think for Kiev if these attacks around
Moscow turn out to have been initiated
by the Ukrainian government because it
will strengthen the narrative that the
Russians have been pushing that of
course Ukraine is trying to attack
Russia of course NATO is behind Ukraine
of course NATO is trying to destroy
Russia none of those things are true but
attacks on Moscow that come obviously
from Kiev will increase that narrative
and the problem for Kiev about that is
not whether the Russians believe it or
not but whether it makes the Western
backers of Ukraine nervous that they're
being pulled into something that they
really can't control the quickest way
for Ukraine to lose this war would be to
attack Russia with Western weapons now
they haven't done that and they say they
won't do that but anything that seems to
cross the line towards doing that will
be very bad for Ukraine in political
terms as of now the big question is
whether Kiev was Behind These drone
attacks and one of the big questions is
whether the drones themselves the UJ 22s
were actually Ukrainian drones and were
they uj-22s that were actually used the
evidence so far is contradictory and
some of the footage that's come out of
of Moscow are clearly not of the uj-22
drones but other bits of film indicate
that they might be and so getting to the
bottom of it forensically will be very
important and that's that's got to be
done I think within the next 24 to 48
hours to stop too many hairs running to
stop too many rumors circulating and the
government in Ukraine have got to get on
top of this issue they've got to make it
clear either it was them and they're
doing it for a reason or it wasn't them
and they can more or less prove that it
wasn't them uncertainty will do Ukraine
a lot of harm